did you ever have anyone telling you
that your work is not messy mesi is one
of these terms used so frequently in
consulting that it's almost a cliche but
what exactly does mesi stand for missy
stands for mutually exclusive
collectively exhaustive it is a rule of
thumb that should be applied whenever
you want to break something down into
smaller parts for instance you might
want to create a document about a topic
and then to break down the topic into
smaller parts for the table of content
mutually exclusive means that the
different parts of your table of
contents should not overlap so you
should discuss the same element only in
one section collectively exhaustive
means that all the parts together should
form the overarching topic again so if
your elements are not overlapping and
complete you likely came up with a good
structure this structure is measy follow
for more insights